glad to be here in the building my guy
thank you for having me you know you
have uh quietly one of the more
influential flows of the last few years
yes yes it's growing it's growing I
won't be surprised when it's up there
I'm gonna be honest with you when I
first heard your song with Drake right
first time I ever heard you
my wife was so tired of me playing this
song we were on vacation like two or
three years ago we were that was like
two years ago we were in Florida
and the song I just can't I just your
flow it was like I thought you were gay
though you know I've seen all those
comments The Sassy show I was like this
bull sassy is [__] I
don't understand it like because you
were like yeah yeah yeah I understand
the comments like you know I've seen all
those comments and Shout like but but
yeah man I mean I've heard so many
artists like
you know take your flow on songs at
times yeah yeah yeah you know there's
like um
did you uh like like I I think shout out
to Bea because should be a kind of did
your flow on that song London yeah yeah
shout out to be uh did she tap in with
you yeah yeah she for sure no she's like
a real one for sure yeah yeah so bio was
actually one of the first industry
people that actually showed love to me
she's great like you know she
she tapped in from way back then yeah
she's OG people don't know she's been
doing her thing for years yeah yeah
super focused so you're originally from
the Toronto area yeah yeah Toronto
Canada you guys are out there uh taking
chains and stuff what's going on oh [__]
yeah I don't know what's going on that's
a little rough out there huh
Sorrell rough draft because we hear like
it's you know it's like Canadians are so
polite yeah at least you know when we
think of like the stereotypical Canadian
as an American I think of like polite
dudes you know Drake's a sweetheart
Justin Bieber
you know like uh there's Canadian bacon
you know you guys get free health care
and then you guys also Rob people when
they don't happen everywhere has its bad
places you know so it's like right
I don't know if people think that they
just think Toronto just saw all the sexy
girls in the world ah I keep hearing
that I keep hearing it's like just like
you go to Toronto and you're like oh the
most beautiful people in the world live
here yeah I hear that all the time I'm
like [__] I guess
what area are you from
um Highland Park Gardens like the west
side of the city okay so sketch area do
you have a good upbringing like a sketch
area for sure but it's mostly like
it's not like that area is more like
drug trafficking than it is
like
like art might get like our people
we're just like not until the Aurora
stuff like it was just mostly making
money you know making money keeping it
and if it has to be like that it's like
that but like no we just make money over
there like there's enough money for all
of us trap Boy [__] real trap boys
because the fentanyl hit Canada yet oh
for sure fennel's everywhere yeah crazy
man I'm so glad I like I never tried it
like I never got in any hard drugs
but anytime I tried any drugs it was
prior to there being fentanyl you know
so it's like now I just eat shrooms yeah
how's that people always tell me [__]
you'll have a good a good [__] high
you know like you won't trip all the
schumers are always say you won't trip
but then out the non-tumors side is like
yo I had a bad trip I won't ever do it
again cause they're [__] [__] yo no
but I don't have a [__] up trip have
you ever had shrooms no Rick I tried
once like the chocolate bar shop well I
don't think they're inconsistent yeah I
don't think I took enough for me to feel
anything so like you got to go in man
you got to go just peel back the layers
of reality I feel like I'll just hi you
might cry yourself in a corner like like
in a fetal position but it'll be you'll
be better for it I'm more of a adderall
type of guy so you like to be a
tentative
I like to like you know I want to be in
the studio for 20 hours yeah I heard
Adderall if you ever want to like edit a
music video in an hour yeah yeah
especially if I know like I'm up this
whole time and I want to stay up even
longer yeah it's meth yeah
like right now I'm I've been sober for a
month good for you hey cold turkey I've
been cold turkey when I go sober I cold
turkey everything I just wake up one day
and say I want a cool turkey [__] and
yeah I have a happy that I'm one month
in right now so so you had like a were
you dependent on the Adderall because I
know a lot of my friends who like are
Engineers yeah yeah like for sure when
I'm drinking and all that stuff and I
need when I I drink too a lot so like
I'm meshing them together it's making me
drink even more than normally
so and I'm staying up longer so it's
like yeah [__] it I was depending on it
for sure and yeah right now I'm not you
know what's the longest you stayed up
it's like two days yeah
yeah yeah
not good for you I'm sure not not good
at all don't do that please was it a
productive two days at least yeah super
productive that's one thing I will say
like when I do drink and all these
things it's not just for fun and games
they I do it for Creative to be more
creative if I'm in a stuck place like
you know that's why I do it but for sure
I've got so much good things out of it
like ideas even talks of my teams like
I'll be it'll be more productive on my
side you know so I don't do it for just
fun and games realistically so I just
found out that you're half Mexican yes
yes yes Mexicano
why did I just find this out you got to
be waving that flag bro I know I know I
know y'all know why oh peso pluma is
done you know y'all know why though
because I don't know Spanish who cares I
know I know but I feel like I want to
get more with the culture first I don't
think do you know who oh Jeezy is yeah
yeah I have a song and a shout out great
guy I'm I'm 90 sure he doesn't know
Spanish
but he looks super due with the culture
you look more Mexican than oh Jeezy
am I lying
oh Jeezy looks like if you told me oh
Jeezy was like like Italian I'd be like
yeah I see it oh yeah I could see the
you know the time but since I now know
you're mad I'm like yeah of course he is
I mean yeah it makes sense you know what
is your other half Haitian and Mexican
that's a great uh that's a very un
common mixture of human in the United
States
and I speak French French is actually my
first language
so yeah yeah I went to like a whole
French school to like grade 10.
and then I went to English school for
like two months and got expelled so you
you like grew up speaking French yeah
yeah yeah like my mom every yeah I was
grow up speaking French but the English
also but French was my first language
wow which side of your uh family is it
your mom your dad's side that's Mexican
Mom Mom's Mexican is she put you on at
all no not really because she was
actually adopted oh okay so she's not
that's why I'm not right because like
she's not
tapped in like that she doesn't know
Spanish herself she knows a [__] she
understands but she doesn't know
you see I don't know yeah a little bit
so she was adopted by um France like her
mom's from France okay so I have like a
whole next family side in Paris the
adopted side yeah yeah yeah yeah but I'm
super tapped in with them also too like
when I go to yeah I go to Paris a lot
too busy yeah
um
my wife is Mexican and my kids are
Mexican so I know probably more Spanish
yeah [__] man I'm gonna get a tutor so I
need a nice Mamacita
have you been to Mexico yeah once which
part Mexico City beautiful yeah yeah
only once but I
that's the only I want to go back you
know yeah I need to happen you need to
help me type in this whole demographic
yeah yeah do you know who MC Magic is
wow
Rob I'm bad I'm bad Vicente Fernandez no
oh [__] Tigres del Norte no one you know
who peso Puma is all right no like I
heard all these names but like um peso
Puma's like the biggest artist in the
world right now still it's like a
Mexican Bad Bunny bro it's crazy you got
to tap in you got the record bruh I'll
tap in with them for sure would you say
his name is again peso Puma peso Puma uh
he's actually I think he's half Lebanese
half Mexican but he's fire
but he's making like real traditional
you know yeah I'm gonna tap in after
this I'm gonna listen to some show